chloe bailey hello and welcome welcome
welcome
i remember chloe
hi i remember when you guys started you
were blessed by beyonce that's a good
start which made a lot of us pay
attention and then we saw your talent
and now we here we are in 2022 you're up
for four bet awards
and for empowering you're it honoring
motivational empowering songs that
center on women so what does this mean
to you when you look at how you guys
started as these cute little girls to
where you are today what does this mean
to you what has this ride been like
the ride has been crazy and so
fulfilling and every single day i wake
up i am filled with such gratitude that
i get to wake up and do what i love and
even right before watching you know how
cis and i started with the youtube
covers and even into now how we have
both branched out into our solo
endeavors it's really really cool to see
how we are shining individually and also
together as a unit and i am so excited
for bet awards i have been you know
grinding it in the studio
and rehearsing every night right after
leaving film set so i'm just ready to
give it my thousand percent all for bet
and
oh i think you're gonna take home a
trophy or two but i love when you said
you've been grinding it we're so used to
the two of you together and now you've
decided to take the step by yourself
what's the difference for you being solo
and why did you decide to do this now
the difference is that i have to
completely believe in myself
and i have to stand in my power usually
if i'm nervous or not or if i don't feel
completely sure about something i'd look
to my left or my right and cis was
always right there and now it's like i
have to fully rely on using my voice and
speaking up for things that i want
changed or say i don't like something
and i'm like okay no and it's like i
have to learn how to be my own boss and
what kind of started this solo endeavor
with the music is like i was at home
filming grown-ish in l.a sisters in
london filming an incredible movie i
can't wait for you to see and i was like
you know what i have all this music i'm
constantly creating i don't just want it
to sit on my hard drive let me release
it out into the world and so that's what
this is so the album is finished i am so
proud of this it's like i get to bring
on the inside of me that the world
hasn't seen and even now i continue to
surprise myself so it's been a very
fulfilling and interesting journey for
sure
nice to surprise yourself i like that
hey chloe it's tony you use your
platform to talk a lot about body image
and the pressure that young girls feel
uh to look a certain way it's been on my
mind lately because i've got a 10 year
old she's in a dance troupe they had
their first big recital performance and
they got these shiny leotards and
they're very tight and my daughter told
me that some of the girls were feeling a
little uh about it i thought oh they're
only 10 but right here we go this is a
whole new era so what is your message to
kids that pre-teenage
who might be thinking like ah this is
not for me or having body image issues
what i would have to say something that
i wish i told myself more when i was
that age because around 10 i was like a
cute little chubby little girl and i
would look around at my friends and i'd
see and i'm like why doesn't my body
look like theirs and it's like
you have to remind yourself and the
youth that you don't have to compare we
are also
incredibly made and none of us are meant
to be the same so i think that would
have to be the number one thing and to
just try to find outlets so when you
have those moments of frustration or
feeling insecure because none of us are
perfect especially now with social media
young kids are going through that even
more than i probably did and i'm going
through it now as a you know a young
woman so i would just have to find an
outlet where you can get that uh you
know that feeling that may not feel so
great out and you know take it so i'm
still learning every day for sure but
that's what i would have to say yeah as
we all are uh nate here uh so you know
you mentioned using your voice beyonce
has always been one of those individuals
that has been a positive influence on
young women allowing them to embrace
exactly who they are you and your sis
you opened up for beyonce on one of her
world tours what are some memories that
come to mind or even lessons that you
take away from queen bee
yes well even before sis and i got
signed to her i
loved her completely and i always looked
up to her and her work ethic and her
drive and i think now seeing it so much
closer it's even more inspiring or i'm
like okay yes it's great to be skilled
in music and produce and engineer my
music but i also have to stay on top of
my work and you know make sure
everyone's like on it and like because
if you don't pay attention things slip
through the cracks so i think that's
been really inspiring watching how she's
like been a boss with her own company
yeah she's been a boss for a long time
chloe bailey we thank you you know that
new song you can't break my soul is out
on a scale of one to ten what do you
have any critiques for beyonce
i have no critique i'd give it as well
i know
i know it's already catchy it could
apply to relationships it could apply to
your job it could apply to so many
things it could apply to yourself i love
this song already already thank you
chloe good luck on sunday good luck on
sunday we're cheering you on
you can watch the
2022 bet awards this sunday night at 8 7
central on b-e-t